okay so today we're going to talk about
this fantastic little puzzle it's called
the 15 puzzle and you can see it's a
tray with 15 little squares each
numbered 1 through 15 and one blank so
we can move the squares around let's say
we want to get these in order so i'm
going to move these around i've got one
two three already and then the third row
should have 9 10
11 12
and then 13 14 15. oh you're good at
that so there we go we can only make
moves where we switch one tile with the
empty spot so i can't switch this one
and that one for example because there's
no blank to move them around in what we
want to talk about with this puzzle is
some of the mathematics behind it so we
went out yesterday and found some
examples of these puzzles that you could
buy in the stores around here and we
found something very interesting on the
back of the package it shows you some of
the patterns that you might try and
arrange the tiles in so the one that we
just did was one through fifteen here
this one has one two three four in
vertical lines rather than horizontal
you might wanna do evens and odds the
various possibilities you could come up
with including a natural one you might
try and do which instead of going from 1
to 15 goes from 15 down to 1 so in
reverse order but this is very curious
try as you might you will never be able
to do this arrangement
so how it ended up on the back of this
package is a real mystery
but
that's the mystery that we want to
explain today so that's like that
they're giving people this impossible
task
it seems like it i don't know what they
were thinking did you play this game
when you were a boy i had several
versions of it including the standard
ones like this i also had some versions
that
instead of having numbers had pictures i
had one that uh had a map of the world
and the the object was to you know
recreate the map of the world but yes i
i certainly wasted more time than i
should have on these puzzles it was
invented in around the 1870s a famous
american puzzle maker named sam lloyd
claimed that he had invented it but
apparently that's not the case but what
he did do in around the early 1870s was
he issued a challenge to the public and
he offered a thousand dollars for to
anybody who could
accomplish this so his challenge was to
take the 15 puzzle in the arrangement
where the numbers are in order 1 through
15 and rearrange it so that 14 and 15
are switched he offered a thousand
dollars for this but the sneaky thing
about this is that this is also an
impossible arrangement but this caused
an absolute national frenzy everybody
was involved in trying to do this a
serious mathematics research journal
called the american journal of
mathematics published a paper called
notes on the 15 puzzle and what the
editors said was the 15 puzzle for the
last few weeks has been prominently
before the american public and may
safely be said to engage the attention
of nine out of ten persons of both sexes
and of all ages and conditions of the
community and then he goes on to say
that this wouldn't have been enough to
persuade them to publish a paper on this
but they felt that it was a chance to
educate the public on some important
mathematical concepts so they were
jumping on the bandwagon actually this
paper is two short notes one proving
that some of the configurations are
impossible and the other saying exactly
which ones were possible okay so the
first thing we have to do is we have to
convert this puzzle into some
mathematical language so that we can use
the tools of mathematics to
to figure out what's going on so let's
first of all just make all of these
things on sort of put them all on the
same footing so let's think of the blank
square as the number 16. so now we've
got the numbers 1 through 16 in some
order
so we're going to focus on those lists
of numbers so each arrangement of the
tiles we're going to think of as some
arrangement of the numbers from 1 to 16.
every time we have a pattern now puzzle
i'm going to
write down the list of numbers 1 through
16 in the order that they appear in the
tray so for example this arrangement
would give me the list 5 1 3 remember
the blank is 16 then 9 2
6
4 13 10 7
8 14 15
12 11. so it's the same set of numbers 1
through 16 just written in a different
order in mathematics that sort of thing
is called a permutation in our case
it's of the numbers from 1
all the way up to 16. at this point i
would have assumed every permutation is
possible if you if you juggle them
around enough times you can list the
numbers in any order right that would be
a reasonable assumption and if that was
possible anything on the back of this
package would have been fair game but so
what we're going to have to show
is that
among all the permutations there are
some which have one property which is
good for us and one which have a
different property which is bad for us
and we're going to use uh this
property that we will identify as a way
to distinguish the possible from the
impossible so let's think about what the
sliding move that we can do is doing to
the permutation so when we slide a piece
we're swapping the blank square from
where it is to where the piece we slid
into it came from 16. so 16 and 4
have switched places if i make that move
if i made that move the blank and three
have switched so 16 and 3 have switched
so the moves we're allowed correspond to
switching
one number with just one other in our
case in the moves from here we can
always switch 16 with something else
let's just say x and i'm going to write
it like that when i write a pair this
means
switch 16 with x if i do that i
obviously get a new permutation so we've
now translated our puzzle into the
mathematical problem starting from one
configuration get to another
configuration by doing switches like
this these are called transpositions so
now that we've translated into
mathematics we
get to use everything that
mathematicians have learned about
permutations and transpositions and
there are a couple of crucial facts that
we need to use so the first fact we can
convert the permutation that we start
with
everything in order into
any other permutation of the same
numbers using
only transpositions so you're including
the impossible ones at this point at
this point those impossible
configurations are within our reach true
if we're free from the constraints of
the puzzle
and are only dealing with the
permutations then we can convert
anyone into any other by these all right
simple example with the permutations
just of one two three
and let's suppose we want to end up with
three one two so how can we convert one
two three into three one two we can
first get three into the place that we
wanted to go by switching three and one
so we make the transposition one three
that will turn this
into three
two one we haven't done anything to two
but we've switched one and three and now
i get the one into place so now i switch
the one and the two and there we are
from there to there by two permutations
if you have longer set of numbers then
you might need more but
that's the idea that by any you can get
from any one to any other just by
switching two at a time so fact two
addresses the fact that there's more
than one way to get from one to another
any we can always do it by
transpositions but for example in the
case of these two permutations i could
have done something different okay now
let me show you a longer one
again going from one two three
two three one two
first
switch the one
and now let me move three over
by switching it first with one
and then with two and now i still have
to get one and two into the right place
so that will take one more switch
switching one and two
that will put this into the right place
so now i've got a chain going from one
two three two three one two
that involves one two three four steps
whereas in our original example we have
only two steps
can you show me a three-step example
i cannot
because of fact two
and fact two
says that even though
there are many ways to get from one
permutation to another
they don't have to involve the same
number of steps
but if one path
involves an even number of steps then
all parts have to have an even number of
steps so the number is not fixed but the
parity whether it's even or odd is fixed
so it could have been orders there are
like with some numbers that will be odd
as well but right for between some pure
mutation so for example if this was the
way we wanted to end up if we wanted to
go from one to three to three to one
then i would have only need one step
so i could have three steps or three
steps or five steps five steps
so the fact number two
the number of steps required is not
fixed but the parity of that number
whether it's even or odd is fixed i'm
taking your word for that that's like
that's like a proven thing right that's
that's we're taking these as facts uh
that uh not just not not just because we
want them to be these are proven facts
right right these are you might even
call them theorems about permutations so
like in the example we did we had one
path that had two steps and one that had
four the number was different but both
were even and i could try until the end
of the universe to to do three and i
wouldn't i wouldn't find it you wouldn't
find it yeah or five or seven or nine
even if i was like duplicating my steps
and things right uh you could write you
could have a sequence where you just
went round and round in a loop for a
while and then cut out of the loop and
made progress that would add a lot of
unnecessary steps but it wouldn't change
the parity of the number of steps so
what this means
is that
starting from the
numbers in order
every other permutation is reached
either by an even number of steps or an
odd number of steps another way of
saying that is we can attach to each
permutation a thing that we might call
an invariant of the permutation that is
the parity of the number of steps needed
to get to it from the starting
configuration now that we know that all
permutations are either even or odd we
will see that the impossible ones have
the wrong parity when we go back to our
puzzle and we want to know
which configurations are possible and
which are impossible we're going to use
this relation to even and odd
permutations and we'll see that if the
arrangement corresponds to a permutation
with the wrong parity then we'll never
be able to get to it one extra
consideration we have to bring in is we
have to look at where the blank space
the number 16 in our permutations starts
and ends so like for example if we
wanted to start with the pieces all in
horizontal row
let's suppose we wanted to get to the
vertical
arrangement
so here we see that in this vertical
arrangement we're going to end up with
the blank square again at the bottom
there so if we start and end with the
number 16 or in puzzle language the
blank square starting in the bottom
right corner and ending in the same
place what's going to happen between
start and finish is that the blank
square is going to move all around the
tray as we make our switching so here
i'll start it we want to get to the
ending configuration so we have to
move the blank square
all around
so that i can rearrange the numbers keep
your eye on the blank square you can see
it's moving all over the board and we
will just keep moving the blank square
around
until the pieces do what we want etc so
let's count how many times we have to
move the blank that will be the number
of transpositions we have to do so you
might think this is an impossible thing
i mean there's going to be maybe dozens
maybe hundreds of moves that we have to
make
but remember all that we care about is
the parity of the number of moves and if
we think about what's going to happen to
this blank square if it's going to start
here and end up at the same place so
let's suppose that when we're doing this
we make a certain number of moves to the
left a certain number of moves to the
right a certain number of moves up and a
certain number of moves down if we're
going to end up at the same place we
have to make as many left as right
because if every time we move left we'll
have to compensate if we're going to end
up back at the same place and the same
with up and down the s the number of ups
will have to equal the number of downs
so the total number
of moves
is the total of the lefts and the rights
and the ups and the downs but the lefts
and the rights are the same so i can
write that as twice the number of lifts
and there are as many downs as up so
that's twice the number of ups so you
can see that whatever the number is it's
twice something it's even it's even so
to end up with the blank or the 16 in
the bottom right corner definitely even
number of modes definitely an even
number of moves so that means if we
start
from
the this configuration
we and we end up with the blank square
in the 16 we can only rearrange this to
correspond to an even permutation all
right so
to prove that this one is impossible
all we have to do now is check whether
the permutation corresponding to this
arrangement is even or odd if it turns
out to be odd then we know we cannot
reach it by these moves
okay how do we do that though that looks
like such a complicated thing to show
all right so let's write out where we
want to start from and where we want to
get to so we want to start from this
configuration and we want to end in the
permutation corresponding to that
arrangement so that starts with 15 so 16
is going to end up in the same place but
all the other numbers
have been rearranged let's construct a
sequence of transpositions that is going
to take this
permutation
to that permutation and this is actually
not too hard so we have to switch 15 and
1.
14 and 2
13 and 3
4 and 12
5 and 11
6 and 10
and 7 and 9 and if you make all those
switches
then you'll get 15 first 14 13 12 you'll
get it in this order of course you can't
make that switch in the puzzle game
quite so easily can you you can't do it
in the puzzle game but without cheating
and taking the tiles right but we know
that the sequence that you would have to
use in the puzzle game would have a
different number of steps but the parity
would be the same
so we only have to worry about parity so
if i can show that with this sequence
the parity is wrong then whatever
sequence we could do there would also be
wrong these are the switches that will
get us from there to there and well how
many of them are there there's one two
three four five six seven so odd that's
enough to tell you that that's it
so that means we cannot get from
the starting configuration in order to
the ending configuration in reverse
order with the blank square in the same
place let's think about
sam lloyd's original
nasty challenge which was to take
the original configuration
and end up with
configuration where everything is the
same except the last two are switched so
if we analyze this using our math
superpowers that we've just acquired we
have to compare our starting
configuration compare this to the
configuration where everything is the
same except i've switched these last
two
tile numbers and 16 stays the same how
many transpositions do we need to get
from the starting one to the ending one
well all we need to do is switch 14 and
15.
so it's the transposition 1415 that's
all we need there's one of them
odd so that's odd but we know from this
little argument that we made if we start
with the blank at the lower right and we
end with the blank in the same place 16
at the end then the number of steps that
we have to have performed to get from
start to finish has to be even all right
so there's no way to start there end
there and do an odd number of steps so
no one won the thousand bucks so no so
sam lloyd
kept his thousand bucks so these other
ones that this package says are possible
are impossible we've got we have to
check all of them we don't know which
ones of those are possible or not right
let's
see if we think it's possible to end up
with the arrangement
where
the numbers go around the board in a
spiral and now we end up
with the blank over there let's see uh
if this should be possible so we're
starting from the standard
starting
configuration so the blank starts in the
bottom right and we want to know can we
end up like this what's the parity of
the number of steps that it would take
to get the blank from starting to its
ending position well it started in the
bottom right to get to where it is at
the end of this configuration we have to
go move one two to the left and one up
so the number of steps has to have the
same parity as three so the fancy math
way of writing that is to say that the
number of steps has to be
one
mod two in other words odd
yeah okay yeah all right that's a very
fancy way all right all right
yeah yeah yeah that's right odd as well
right right under right right okay sorry
unnecessarily
rather
odd
one month yeah yeah okay so it's odd so
it's odd so whether this is possible or
not then depends on whether the
configuration corresponding to this
which is 1 2 3
4
12 13 14
5
11. remember blank is 16
15
6
10 9 8 7
is that odd so this one it's not as easy
to draw a map in the same way there but
we can certainly figure out a path from
the starting configuration to there
how we're going to do it so we don't
have to do anything about the first four
12 13 14 in the starting configuration
are over there they all have to be moved
to come after one two three four so we
can do that let's see twelve would have
to be switched with eleven then ten then
nine and eight and seven and six then
five so that's one two three four five
six seven hops that would put the 12 in
front of the five then the 13 can come
behind it another seven hops and the 14
behind that another
seven we can get this match correct by
doing we had to do seven hops for the
twelve seven for the thirteen and seven
for the fourteen so that's going to take
three times seven odds those odd hops
odd odd numbers so far
okay now
five is in the right place as well so
we're good up to there uh we have to get
11 into the correct place behind the
five so that's going to take five hops
now we're good up to 11. now we need the
16 that's going to be one two three four
five another six hops now we're good up
to there 15 into its correct position
that's going to take one two three four
five hops nine ten that was another one
now we've got fifteen six happens to be
in its right position
so now we've got to just switch the last
few we've got to get
seven eight nine ten into the order ten
nine eight seven here
we can actually we can short circuit
things we switch those two and those two
that will do the job so that's another
two that's odd don't even need to know
the actual number all we need to know is
it even or odd here we have another 10
steps that's even so an even number plus
an odd number is odd good news because
look up here good news right because
that's what we wanted good news that's
that's gettable so let's do it
you can edit this
c
mathematics wins okay
i'm going to make a prediction the
number of people on the youtube video
that write comments saying oh i just
take the tiles out or i cheat and things
like that is going to be
odd
odd but not peculiar odd and a lot of
them
elements here which these are not quite
tetris because tetras is four squares
these have five so these are five
squares so these are all the possible
ways you can put five squares together
if you were to stop right now this is
area 20. so if you were to stop right
now your score would be 20 that's your
biggest minus your smallest four your
score would be 16.